meeting resumed at 13 40. uh the next
item is a motion from councilor
spenceley councilor spenceley
thank you chair
so I'm going to read my Preamble because
I think that's most straightforward so
in December 2022 Essex County Council in
its capacity is the flood Authority
adopted the Essex flood risk management
plans for flood risk areas these plans
look at seven flood risk areas across
the county so these seven plans are
obviously the priority plans that have
been adopted
the detail for one of those seven plans
reads as follows between 2021 and 2027
the environment agency will work with
Essex County Council and Morden District
Council to develop options in haybridge
to reduce the risk of fluvial tidal and
surface water flooding in the combined
Essex management catchment
at the time of writing this motion no
approach for discussion with haybridge
members has been made by officers of
either this Council Essex County Council
or the environment agency
it is feared that without organized
regular and proactive engagements that
includes members of this Council who
represent the residents of the affected
area that once again the chance to
realize an appropriate flood alleviation
scheme for haybridge In the period up to
2027 will be effectively reduced and
quite possibly lost
I therefore move the following motion
that at its meeting on the 22nd of
February 2023 Council resolves to agree
to work in a proactive manner to engage
with all appropriate authorities to
pursue the realization of a flood
alleviation scheme for haybridge and
that with this in mind it recognizes the
need for invitation to involvement of
all haybridge World members and other
members as appropriate through the
formation of a haybridge flood
alleviation scheme working group
so what I'd like to say very quickly
about this is that it's enormously
important as I'm sure everyone
appreciates for the hundreds of
residents in Highbridge who are now in
flood zone 3A
and that while I appreciate is I'm sure
we're going to hear that work's been
going on behind the scenes with regards
to this the haybridge world members feel
that they do need to be involved and
that I'd like a working group and I
believe they would like a working group
going forwards to help
um promote this as you know in haybridge
um
we've been let down before and we don't
really feel that we want to be let down
again and I'm representing residents who
on the door are deeply distressed and
quite worried about the value of their
homes
about what will happen in the future
and I just think this is absolutely
essential and I really hope that Council
will support this motion today thank you
Mr Dodson
thank you chairman
um
it's very timely actually that this um
this um motion has come forward
um because as the member says work has
been ongoing through the coastal and
flooding group and in direct dialogue
with the environment agency
progress has been reported via the
coastal and flooding group and Council
officers have had meetings with the
environment agency to progress their
ongoing work on business planning for a
haybridge flood alleviation scheme
whilst the environment agency had asked
officers not to discuss outside of those
direct meetings until the business
planning process was confirmed
happily I'm now able to share some
further information having spoken to the
environment agency in the in the last
week
and this this was a statement that the
environment agency have given me to to
update members
until recently the haybridge flood
alleviation project had been paused
since 2020 and whilst the environment
agency had sought commitment towards
partnership funding from local
stakeholders
and whilst bids for other sources of
potential funding were being applied for
in July 2022 the project was successful
in obtaining a provisional allocation of
2.3 million from the environment agency
administered other government
departments fund
this element of funding significantly
supplements the eligible flood defense
granting Aid available to the project
and has greatly reduced the large
dependency on partnership funding which
would otherwise have had to be sourced
from local organizations
and beneficiaries such as modern
District Council and Essex County
Council some partnership funding from
local sources and organizations outside
of the environment agency will still be
required to help deliver the scheme but
the project is now more viable than it
was at this time last year
consequently the environment agency is
now in a position to take the project
forward to outline business case
appraisal stage that must first produce
a business case update report for its
Financial assurers to agree to further
spend on developing the business case
during Financial year 2023-24
this work on the business case update
report is progressing currently and the
environment agency hoped to soon be in a
position to procure a consultant to
deliver the outline business case during
Financial year 2324.
it is confirmed that it will keep
Council officers and members briefed on
progress through the regular modern
District Council Coastal and flooding
group and flood maintenance and projects
group meetings until formal public
engagement and consultations take place
as an integral part of the outline
business case development
the outline business case will look to
refine four previously identified
preliminary options and these were
shortlisted in 2019 following
stakeholder workshops attending by the
by the environment agency modern
District Council Essex County Council
and Essex Waterway staff
and
members were briefed
um from the Malden District Council
Coastal and flooding group back in July
2019.
the four options now being evaluated are
number one
diversion of high flows from the maypole
road ditch the Headwater of the Holloway
road ditch to The Langford ditch north
of Langford Road and onward diversion to
the river Blackwater and the tidal River
chelmer at biele Via Elms Farm Country
Park and the Chalmer and Blackwater
navigation Canal utilizing the existing
Canal lock floodgates adjacent to the
a414 mold and bypass
option two diversion of high flows from
both the maypole road ditch and the
Langford ditch South Westwoods to the
river black water and tidal River chalma
at beeley this will require the
construction of a new chunker to take
High flows to the west of the Langford
cup
option three Improvement of flow
conveyance through existing Holloway
road ditch and Langford ditch systems
Elms Farm canal chunker and Langford
ditch east of canal through to sad dance
loose
option four property level protection
measures to properties most frequently
at risk of flooding
the first three potential options relate
to the construction of new assets
diversionary water courses or physical
measures to improve flow conveyance
through the existing Watercourse system
those measures are aimed at reducing the
frequency and magnitude of flooding in
the Holloway Road and Elms Farm estate
areas of haybridge
the fourth option of property level
resilience looks to reduce the magnitude
of flood damages by adapting the
property's most susceptible to frequent
flooding in order to make them more
resilient to flood in I.E it doesn't
modify the frequency of flooding from
the water courses themselves only looks
to minimize the damages
as stated earlier and as part of the
outline business case the environment
agency will be undertaken public
engagement consultation exercise into
more detailed briefings during 2023-24
so that that's the the statement I was
given and I'll obviously share that with
members through the minute so that
everybody's got got that detail because
I realize I've given a lot of
information verbally there
um just to add the office of you on this
is that the council should set up a
member reference group similar to that
in place for the a12 consultation to
keep members informed alongside the the
um flood and Coastal group and to
support the officer Representatives
working with the environment agency as
this work progresses thank you chairman
um thank you Mr Dodson uh members
is that the handout councilor still
please um thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you Mr Dobson for that report I
actually do agree with councilor
spencerley and and setting up a working
group in my mind would be better because
the people of haybridge the members of
haybridge are the ones that know this
area really well I think we've also got
to be aware that this
water level is rising we do have
problems with flooding and it's not just
heybridge it is the whole of Malden that
has a flooding problem and has a had a
flooding problem for years
and I think we should be looking into
developing a real good flood plan for
Malden as well because we are building
in more areas and those areas could
flood the other thing is
moving drainage dishes moving water
courses can then mean that there's
flooding elsewhere because you're just
moving that flow into a different
bottleneck so I I would support that we
had the working group
um Mr Dodson wants to come back
thank you the the environment agency
will be forming a
um their own group on on this and
they'll be modeling obviously all of the
the potential outcomes from from
diversions to this as part of their
business
um case development
um clearly hear what the members are
saying around a working group what I'm
what I guess I'm unclear on is what the
working group would do in its terms of
reference because you know what I'm
suggesting is a reference group to feed
into the work that's being driven by the
environment agency
we wouldn't be the ones delivering that
work we need to feed into it hence why I
I say a reference group so just wanted
some clarification on that from members
to understand what's being proposed
thanks
councilor white
um thank you Mr chairman I mean firstly
um let's be quite clear I was against
this uh this housing development in
haybridge and I didn't trust the
developers to do what they were said
they were going to do and lo and behold
here we are as always there's always a
financial constraint why they can't do
what they say they're going to do but um
anyway that's down for plenty inspector
and not us
um but what I would say is
um having been involved with the
shoreline management plan even before I
was on the council I don't know was it
20 years ago that started I can't even
remember now
um we large sways of RC walls are either
no end of intervention or they're just
doing nothing to them
um and I I I don't see that this is just
a hay bridge this seems to be all about
haybridge but we should be working as a
district not just haybridge
um and also we can't form a working
group on this we have to rely on the
environment agency and they just don't
move very quickly they're the ones who
do the model they're the ones who have
the plans in place they're the ones who
decide where the water goes they do all
the modeling we can't do that even if we
have a working group
so I'm suggesting oh I would like to
bring them in that we have the reference
group as suggested by officers and that
all the haybridge members are on there
so they have an input and we wait for
the updates by the environment agency
because we can't make updates we can
make representations but we can't
unfortunately do anything with it I mean
I've been trying to get sea walls
protected for years and in fact I was
the first person in the UK to get
permission to rebuild AC wall because
because I got the environment agency to
say what the emergency circumstances
were that's how slow it is dealing with
the environment agency so as I say my
amendment is that we have a reference
group as suggested by Paul Dodson but we
don't just do heybridge this isn't just
about heybridge we have problems in my
ward we have problems in moldum we have
problems in Burnham and I'd like to see
it so that it's District wide looking
also at heybridge
um and that's that's my amendment I
think I think uh councilor white that I
can't accept that as an amendment a big
does it
provides the uh the purpose of the the
gates is the word I was looking for
thank you Council
the motion Mrs essentially you've made
your proposal and you'll have the
opportunity to sum up at the end
well uh
um
no she she could come back when she does
her summing up at the end
um
councilor stand
um yeah thank you I'm pleased we've got
an update I'm just so sad it's taken so
long actually I can remember having
meetings when I was the leader and I did
actually message Mr Dodson to ask I
thought hold on a minute this was
covered a long time ago
um
um I actually do support this motion and
I support it most probably with an
amendment if the officers can get the
similar to what I thought councilor
white was going to say but then she went
to included the whole District which I'm
afraid I can't but that's the pabis
members do form part of that reference
group so it feeds into it they may only
meet once every six months or once
whatever but at least then you can have
something you won't you won't get it I
don't think you'll get it any other way
because we all deal with the environment
agency and Council White's very true we
actually managed I've got a confidential
report which I'm not allowed to share
about the seawall I any Burnham on Crash
because they they do not allow you to to
give the information out on reports
which I've find very frustrating and I'm
sure all members do so I think in
essence chairman I haven't really got
any questions I think the motion is is
right I think it's um you know and I can
certainly see the reasons behind it and
I agree with councilor white I can
remember sitting at the uh hearing VIP
hearings and the suggestion was to build
houses on stilts and I never heard
anything so ridiculous because we knew
the houses weren't going to be built on
stilts German no I'm not I'm not being
facetious that's what that was actually
said at the hearing
um can I ask a question one question Mr
Dodson you you said the four options and
you said about
um property protection how can you
mitigate property protection do you give
them extra sandbags because we know it's
going to flood because it's it's um
inherent you said that you can't change
the amount of times it's flood but what
would that entail because I find it
really strange that you're going to
consider four options and one if I lived
in one of those houses I I there's no
way how are you going to mitigate and
stop me getting flooded without moving
out of my house because I've got all my
plaster has to come off and you've blown
all my fuses from my appliances thank
you I'm rather confused um
because I think you was going to move or
you you suggesting that suggested an
amendment
was it yet because members might want to
say have you heard of that councilor
Lagan
[Music]
oh sorry Mr Dodson have you got an
answer yes I'm I'm not the expert on
this so I don't know all of the detail
but there are obviously things that you
can do to make properties more resilient
to to being
to the existing conditions whether
that's removing some of the
um
changing some of the accesses to houses
along Holloway road that would free up
that that ditch more but I know that in
in other cases there are houses that
have been flooded previously where all
of the the sockets are moved up the wall
it's it's not stopping them flooding
it's preventing the damage that is
linked to flooding and it you know it
does say that it's not going to stop it
it just makes the properties more
resilient if they are flooded I think I
was I think I was on the flood defense
uh committee uh uh a stage when money
for Malden was
um asked for uh and um it wasn't
forthcoming but the county members do
have
as I was a county member and on the
flood defense committee
um a member or members on that so I I
think
um as an aside perhaps the county
members could get on to whoever that
representative is uh to put pursue the
hybrid issue that's an aside councilor
Lagan
thank you I've got a couple of things um
questions to Mr Dodson do we know and
they can't you can't give in exactly
pensions and Pence them out but you know
how much money they're talking about for
an alleviation scheme
first question
yeah
yes I think the figure I I quoted was
2.8 million
2.3 million sorry that had been been
awarded I understand the figure is
probably around 2.8 million in total but
there's as well as that 2.3 million
there was another fund that was
referenced within this uh so that was
the other government departments fund
and it supports supplements the eligible
flood defense Grant in Aid that's
available which I think takes it up
towards that 2.8 million 2.8 to 3.2
around that I think was the the figure
so I think you know there's a very small
in in real terms Gap at the end of it
but obviously that will be refined
through the business planning process
that they're going to go through now
a couple of points wouldn't be right if
I didn't give me three minutes
um I've got the money the project which
is good the modeling which is excellent
modeling the environment agency will do
that you can give us what they want
um I just want to share a personal story
very quickly with members I lived in
Queensland in 2007 when when Makai
flooded
and we had flooding's no joke it's um
it's absolutely immense I've never seen
anything like it in my life I've seen
fridges cars you know roads eroded
people die it was it was it really
um
I'd say life-changing if I'm brutally
honest with you you know it's it's
something so we've got to make sure we
get this right and I went I went jogging
before the bypass with the Link Road was
open and the day before and I spoke to
the guy and they said they've elevated
the road up by two meters which worried
me a little bit because the water is
going to come down two meters on the
developments and I'm not sure that I'm
no expert it's just a feeling the
ditches are
um up to capacity and they're only just
started to clean them out so I'm worried
about that
um but it is it is a real issue you know
because when it floods in 1953 we did
have the terrible flood that a terrible
loss of life and if you look on the news
um you see obviously areas in the UK
flood dramatically and the water's got
to go somewhere so I hope
um however this this goes I hope that
they do get it right because from
personal experience it is is devastating
um and from a perspective of emotion I I
support the motion um because I think it
is very important in its content that
links into what Mr Dodson said with what
the work they enroll agency does against
what the other groups are doing as well
so there's a lot of good work going on
by the sounds of it Council Swain
uh thank you chairman
um I tried to raise this as an issue for
Owen has to look at some time ago the
main reason being that um there are
various agency involved not just the EA
um but angling water a district council
highways and a private owner the private
properties owners in um that affect the
area
um so
um they all need to be taken into
account their contributions and the
point of my query through our own death
was to try and establish who is exactly
responsible for which assets of the
existing system and whether they're
doing their job or not
um so we have the EA it's not entirely
an EA issue and whether the money money
is going to be adequate by the time they
do get a business case through I guess
it's going to be a lot more than three
million
um there's never seems to have been
enough for it
um and if they're looking at these
options I I would guess that um they
really need more than one they need to
combine them in some way they're only
more than just one of these options to
actually
what should we say to complete the task
and that may well go and they'll be on 3
million and therefore big big postponed
a bit further as far as having the um
working group concerns and the reference
group
um there is
um the ref the reference group is only
for the EA and I think we need to
um in invoke
discussions or
um interrogation of what all his other
bodies can and should should have been
doing probably including the district
council and certainly highways
um but
um the the question with a working group
is
um
who it would report to and I don't think
the working group as a working group
would be able to
call on all these other authorities to
ask them to quiz them on what they're
doing but Owen s does have that um
that sort of what should we say remit
um so I I but my question is um
could it could this working group
actually report through o and S or would
it report to council
um I'm not quite sure how it would work
um I don't know whether Mr dozen wants
to answer but I'm sure the leader will
will be able to
um
explained in her
penultimate speech and Leslie yes
thank you chairman yes the the flood and
Coastal group actually does a lot of
that that work presently brings together
those groups the environment agency
Essex County Council uh anglian water
um and it brings them to have that that
discussion and and make sure that
there's a full understanding of the the
responsibilities of all of those those
groups and the the the the aim of that
group is to hold them to account within
it and also I'd say that the the
environment agency through the they'll
be setting up a reference group
themselves or a strategy group in terms
of external stakeholders supporting
their business case process which is
what we as a council will engage with
them on and they've asked that they'll
be officer representation on that and
the reference group would then inform
that that officer engagement but
similarly to
um Malden District Council being on that
I would expect those other stakeholders
Anglia water Essex County Council all to
be on that group as well so in the
context of that that flood alleviation
scheme that's how they'll all be
informed but also held to account by the
environment agency for their
responsibilities in the area
thank you
um going back to what you were saying
earlier about
a regional flood board and speaking to
the members on that
I feel that part of the sort of problem
has been is that there is a regional
flood and Coastal committee which is
Norfolk Suffolk and Essex but actually
there hasn't been a Malden District
Essex County councilor on that for a
while I don't think I think there are
two from tendering one from Colchester
and one from Rochford but currently
we're not Representatives so we're not
on top of the priorities their arms oh
sorry yes so no I had sort of made a
note that I would talk to committee
Services
um because some one of us should be on
there
um because it's a it's a levy thing they
vote that's where all the money is
decided so uh yeah something we'll get
on with
um and then going back to councilor
Swain's
um points I think
to I mean Paula and I have discussed
this for Shirley I think it would be a
really useful exercise
um if somebody did map all of the assets
um I just because maintenance is part of
the solution yeah thank you
who have I got next to anybody
um it comes to the leader then
um thank you chairman
um I counselor Stanford you heard said
this body's been going for quite a while
and she sat out when she was leader so
equally and you know there's councilor
Spencer because we have spoken I do and
councilor Thompson's also on it and it
is a body
um that has obviously had the flood
alleviation scheme as one major agenda
item but there are other areas it looks
at as well
and I understand where you're coming
from and I'm not trying to malign what
you're trying to intend here but I do
feel that the working group and I'm
going to be very Frank is not the best
vehicle I actually do think a reference
group and you've heard what Mr Dodson
says I think you'll have greater
influence with the reference group than
the working group being set up by this
Council and going and Reporting who
knows where or duplication whereas from
the EA and what the the structure
they'll have to set up regarding the
business case acceptor and the reference
group we've heard Mr Dobson speak about
officer representation I think it's very
important that heybridge members then
are able to feed into that and that
influences them put directly into the EA
in this scheme going forward I I do
think and I'm not trying to you know and
as I say malign what you're trying to
achieve but I don't think the working
group is the is the body and I think Mr
dodson's has highlighted uh the way that
could operate and I think that will
actually engender more influence and
input than perhaps the working group so
I'm not being over critical about your
working group I just think you want to
get the biggest way of influencing and I
believe it is that way of feeding up and
getting and both ways of course I'm not
talking about just up and down it's got
to be totally interactive across the
three and I do think with all due
respect that is the way to go
thank you uh would you like to sum up
councilor spencerley
having listened to all this I'm quite
prepared to go for the reference group
and so I would like that amended so that
it's a haybridge
um flood alleviation reference group if
we can have it called that I would I
would also like to make the point while
I'm here about something that counselor
white said very quickly I do appreciate
that there are other areas of modern
District that have flooding but this is
one of seven schemes that's been
highlighted and adopted by Essex County
Council for for the whole of Essex
including thurrock I understand so it
wouldn't be there it would not be on it
would not be there if it wasn't for the
fact that it is such a heavy need and in
case anyone thinks it isn't I will
quickly say one thing further to
something that councilor Lagann said yes
it's only Holloway Road we're not being
swept away and yet a few years ago I had
a neighbor who disappeared in the dark
under the water in that ditch and so I I
you know it is perhaps more serious than
people realize I've been out many times
now at five o'clock in the morning with
sandbags Richard Holmes has actually
taken calls from my husband while I was
laying sandbags out the front where
we've been trying to find out who was
responsible for the for the blocked
Culver opposite so I you know it is
important and I hope members will
support that with that change to a
reference group thank you
um
but that's an amendment moved by the uh
motion mover
um
and seconded by counselor white
I think that that concludes it
um so with that change from councilor
spenceley
um I'm I'm not sure you you are you
saying that you're
go with a reference group
you'll go with the reference group and
you're not moving this motion
I want the working group
just changing one word okay right as
long as I understand it and everybody is
Happy uh do members agree that
thank you uh Mr Miss bird
um are you clear on that
thank you
uh now I need a motion to go into Pro
private Services as a session and I've
I've proposed a resolve the under
Section 100a for the Local Government
Act 1972 the public we excluded from the
meeting for the following item of
business on the grounds it involves the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph two of part one
of schedule 12a to the ACT Mr quelch
should I add anything else to that on
this particular issue I think it's
paragraphs one two and three one uh
paragraphs one two and three
second Tour by to the ACT and this
satisfies the public interest test
members agree secondary agreed that's
agreed then miss bird so can you stop
the Stream